[Music]
the pandemic has forced governments from
both sides of the political divide
globally to support a bigger state and
massive spending to sustain livelihoods
and companies but despite this
despite this political convergence
divisions in society are deep and
profound with many people feeling
disenfranchised by a political system
that seemingly offers no radical change
is this convergence a short-term blip
will parties on the left and right soon
form new agendas will they give voice to
dissent
or is the current convergence not
temporary but an inevitable result of
democracy as the need to win majorities
forces both sides into the center
or
are we seeing the transition to a new
form of politics altogether in which
traditional notions of left and right
are abandoned
we've got four fantastic speakers who
are going to be talking about that for
us today
peter lilly is a british conservative
party politician and member of the house
of lords he was a cabinet minister in
the governments of margaret thatcher and
john major and has been a long-term
critic of the european union
paul mason is a british political
commentator and radio personality a
former member of the radical workers
power group paul describes his politics
as now quotes very complicated peter
manelson is a british labour party
politician who's held positions as
secretary of state for trade industry
and northern ireland he's a former
european trade commissioner and british
first secretary of state
and ella whelan is freelance journalist
commentator and author well known for
her defense of both women's freedom and
free speech and she is an organizer of
this year's battle of ideas we're going
to start with three uninterrupted
minutes the last uninterrupted minutes
any of you will probably have just to
lay out your thoughts on the core
question which is
are the left and right converging and do
we need more radical solutions to the
many problems that we see before us and
which politics surely has to solve and
i'll start if i may with peter lilly
normally
the first pass the post system in the uk
in america and elsewhere
means that parties do converge they have
to overlap
they can't afford to go out and extreme
and seed the center ground to the other
side
but something gone wrong it hasn't been
working in america to a lesser extent
here in a number of other countries
why is that
now my analysis and i put it forward as
hypothesis and i'm particularly
interested to hear peter mendelsohn's
views on it is that the labour party the
left in most countries has always
consisted of a coalition between the
intellectuals who believed in socialism
and the organized working class who
provided the vote uh and usually
moderated the opinions of the
intellectuals if you read george orwell
you'll see he says that
almost all socialists are middle class
they have
contempt for the working class but they
need them they need the organized
working class to deliver the vote and
get them into power and that forces them
to moderate their views and their
opinions
and indeed to conceal their contempt for
the working class with whom they're
working
uh now what has happened
is that the organized working class in
most countries
has lost power has lost its base trade
union membership has fallen it hasn't
been there at the same time
the intellectual class people who've
been to university like all of you and
learned to manipulate words have become
more powerful and many of them
are socialists and they feel that
they're probably the majority they're
not of course
and they think they can go it alone
without the organized working class they
go to an extreme
and they lose
or
they create an opportunity for the other
party to go to it extreme that's what
happened in america
the
democrats went to extreme
hillary clinton
hillary clinton actually described the
working last voters as a bunch of a
basket of contemptibles
and they reacted as you would if someone
said that they despised you
uh but that gave an opportunity for
trump to go out to another extreme he
won one actually lost the next
uh in this country
jeremy corbyn took the labour party to
an extreme with the consent of a massive
new membership of the labour party
and it's going to be very difficult for
it to get back to the center i think
it's important that it does because i
want conservatives to win elections
generally from time to time it's
important they lose and that we have an
alternative government and at the moment
we don't have an alternative government
and i don't know how that's going to
happen when you've got intellectuals who
despise the working class having
revealed their contempt and the working
class having said thank you very much
we'll vote for the other lot
thanks very much uh peter for that
introduction just as a very quick straw
poll um everyone here who went to
university please stick up your hands
everyone who didn't go to university
please stick up your hands
okay so i'd say that the vast majority
did in fact uh go but just worth
checking that out on a a a factual basis
good to good to know uh paul mason could
i turn to you are we converging on left
and right do we need more radical
solutions well of course um we've now
discovered that we need a big state but
we didn't discover it because of covid
we discovered it when the financial
system of the world collapsed in 2008
and the state saved the market uh that
would run so far against uh the accepted
wisdom and economics that many people
were shocked
but there is a bigger
issue facing us even than our financial
collapse and that is climate change
i would say for the last hundred years
what characterized one of the
characteristics of left politics uh and
i am off the left has been a relaxed
attitude towards time so you get the the
kia hardy generation believed you know
they would only be trusted with power if
they could educate themselves and
organize and build up the labor
movement's strength rosa luxembourg the
german revolutionary murdered in 1919
on the last article she wrote before
being extrajudicially killed said you
know the revolution marches to victory
through a series of defeats both the
reformist and revolutionary traditions
of the left believed they had time
martin luther king quoting a 19th
century uh clergyman said you know the
arc of the universe is long but it bends
towards justice he should have added
eventually
climate change places a ticking clock in
the agenda of every political tradition
and my argument would that is we just
either we decarbonize the world by the
middle of this century or we spiral into
a series of shocks and aftershocks that
we cannot predict the social and
economic outcome of
i would argue that what now
characterizes the left and it may indeed
be that left that peter doesn't like the
one that has educated that i would argue
is forms a new working class
um what characterizes it is that he's
now prepared to take time seriously and
take urgency seriously what i think we
will see pan out in politics the most
important whether or not the electorate
understands this it's for us those who
do understand it to lead we will now see
play out the following debate what are
you prepared to do to decarbonize the
economy of this country the left answer
is
make inroads into the wealth and power
of capitalists
because we've tried it the market way
we've tried it through carbon cap and
cap and trade uh through permits we you
know we looked we took a four billion
year old planet screwed it up with 250
years of carbon capitalism and then
thought that
a system invented uh 25 years ago the
mark you know the free market capitalism
could solve it it hasn't we're going to
have to take away
the ownership of the energy system from
the private sector but i think that's
why the left cannot be missed you will
never mistake us on a dark night for the
people who are going to let this planet
fly and will be responsible for ecocide
by the middle of the century um ella
thank you uh well i don't think that
left and right are converging though it
can be difficult to figure out what they
stand for anymore i think that's the
main point that both those on the left
and those on the right at least in
mainstream sense have had their
ideologies hollowed out i mean what it
means to be right now right wing is
really anything that's not lefty and
what lefty means is really become rather
superficial i mean sort of being nice to
people maybe arguing for a few food
banks here and there
and having a problem with open
discussion around issues like race and
gender and identity politics and i could
sit here and say you know the solution
and the and as the question asks the
need for more radical solutions is to
re-establish what left and right means
you know for left-wing is to get serious
about us arguing for economic revolution
uh you know rather than just relying on
kyocera trying to hobble the prime
minister over 20 quid here or there on
universal credit i also could say to my
opponents on the right well you need to
get more serious about arguing for the
capitalist class that you need to get
more serious about cracking down on uh
the tendency to be socially liberal that
you know you should start being real
bosses rather than uh lecturing your
workers on which charity to give to and
whether or not to ride a bike or drive a
car to work because at least then i'd
have some kind of opponent to um to
bounce off of but i think that this
obsession really with uh whether or not
we can figure out what left or right
means anymore is the fundament it's the
misunderstanding of today's political
crisis which is that it's not uh an
absence or left or of left or right that
is really crippling us but it's an
absence of democracy and that's part of
today's title descent division and
democracy it is the deficit of democracy
and a misunderstanding of what democracy
means that i think is really
putting a barrier between any kind of
radical solutions or political change
now obviously the right have never been
particularly uh enamored with democracy
they don't really like the idea that and
the pauper or the worker should have as
much say in politics or how the world is
run than um the professor or indeed the
expert or the capitalist um but the part
of the problem is that the left who may
be perhaps one some of them um argued
for freedom freedom of speech well you
know from thomas rainsborough to fred
hampton saying that the every man that
every man or woman could have as much
say as the as the highest in society
that's gone you know today people are
not to be trusted they're not to be
trusted with important things like
climate change if you give too much
access to social media john will turn
into a troll if you give too much
ability for jane to speak freely she'll
probably turn into a bigot i think the
real radical idea we have to look at is
as rather than left and right as whether
you are a democrat or an anti-democrat
and i mean that in the abstract sense
whether you really take seriously the
idea that politics and the shaping of
the world is for everyone to get to be
involved in rather than just you know
being obsessed with which party stands
for what and for the final introductory
thought on that question are the left
and right converging do we nibble
radical solutions peter manelson
well rana let me put the uh correct the
record straight away and let peter lilly
know that i i did not join the labour
party and i do not consider myself on
the left of british politics because i'm
an intellectual who despises the working
class
the reason why i'm on the left in
politics and the reason why i support
the labour party
is because i believe
in
in a politics
in which uh
you you align yourself
with other people who think similarly
who believe in a party
of conscience
and reform
conscience
because you are concerned about those
who have less and who want more
and you want to lean heavily against
inequalities in society you want to
create
the opportunities
and the freedom that comes from a
strong
enduring platform of public services
in your country from which people can
derive real uh freedom
also
a society in which people recognize that
they have
both rights individual rights but also
obligations and responsibilities
so that's how i would define the left
and i believe that uh the left uh has as
valid a set of credentials and ideas and
proposals that it's always uh had i'm
not so sure however
that those on the left organize
themselves with as much efficacy as they
have done in the past and that's why
we tend to lose elections rather than
win them my last point is this what is
driving both left and right
in a particular direction and that
direction is in
does see
an expanding role for the state and a
higher level of public spending
than we thought was necessary or
desirable over the last 30 years
is not ideology and it's not focus
groups it's a combination of demography
and science and technology
demography because we have an aging
population where people's health care
needs and their care demands are growing
and where the state
has to respond properly but also science
and technology
because as paul mason has said
we are grappling uh with a climate
emergency and that climate emergency has
to be addressed beyond borders and
internationally not by into by ideology
but by climate science and new
technologies as it will be in the coming
decades so it's not politics that's
driving us towards the center in that
sense it's policy the policy that arises
from shifts in demography and the policy
that is demanded by science and
technology to address the climate crisis
that we are experiencing
peter thanks very much and thank you all
for for really thoughtful introductions
to this debate
let's start by a little discussion on
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas
you